I'm just trying to say a word for
science maybe I'm just being overly
sensitive but what I sense here is
very very tell philosophy and
philosophers
there and no attempt to do anything with
this scientists I mean this may be an
exaggeration for we're not doing the
experiments right we're dealing Labette
experiment right for not doing
understanding kind of research properly
and for writing books about
consciousness which are bad and yet this
I mean maybe this is implicit in the
whole conference that science has done
good stuff without I mean what what this
to me the hook arms has been it's been a
philosophically dominated catering to
philosophy and how great it is and I
just wanted to speak to oh yeah I know I
was worried somebody wouldn't be
contentious defensive science doesn't
show you nor philosophy I can get almost
uncontroversial and so I find you get my
little an example of a case where the
philosophers clearly dropped the ball
and could have done better
yeah so really you would be nortis
anyway but still a case where a really
some compelling mechanistic explanation
of some phenomena was generated because
of an intervention by philosophy which
whichever field biology physical where
that really changes the Jacobs game
mounting account
Einstein's description of special
relativity in the role of live elites in
Berkeley and Ernst Mach in his thinking
it's pretty good
okay if I'm right about quantum
mechanics it will be lithium look I
think there are cargos those are
beautiful
there are mainstream examples you you
can't in cosmology come up with a theory
which puts human beings as special
without getting a lot of flack for that
I mean this is you know clearly a
massive shift starting with Copernicus
and onward where it's just you know it's
it's it's it's a philosophy that human
beings should not be special and it's
mainstream and it's you know may or may
not be very deep but it clearly it's not
acceptable anymore and to the point
where we're string theorists and
cosmologists are arguing very hard about
things like the landscape the
possibility that there's multiple
universes that that the only reason why
the universe looks this way just happens
to be because we're here asking about
either these sort of anthropic
principles and they are debated heavily
among the hard-core string theorists
scientists and whether it's a it's an
acceptable program to pursue or it's a
weak program to pursue the anthropic one
for just for example yeah absolutely
absolutely and I think you know and I
think being expected to be good at that
is a fair you know criterion just like
you're expected to be good at your
experiment it's a fair you know level at
which we should have hold or our work
help the scientists or can it you know
ask questions maybe not design
experiments but I think this sort of
simple-minded answer is that wants to be
helped us decide as if some questions
are interesting right that's one the
other one is more to that would help we
should be so lucky
the other ones to give it an interesting
account of what counts as an explanation
that would actually really help right so
I have my own pre theoretical intuitive
sense of what I think a causal
mechanistic explanation is in my world
and I kind of make it up as it but I
think it's you know I try to convince
myself that it makes
you know I postulate a set of primitives
and then I try to use the interactions
between those to account for the
phenomena and a principled manner
hopefully can even formalize that Steve
Weinberg's point that he was pointing
towards a different example but you know
it's not that we don't use philosophy
it's that we often just use bad
philosophy better philosophy that's
right that's the kind that's of flavor
it doesn't really help it's actually is
fascinating because sometimes I mean I
don't think I shared Jerry coins view
that this is a celebration and of how
great philosophy is but you know I do
feel sort of genius like goodbye you
know at the end so here's a very
specific question I can ask David
because I told you how I thought your
work me and I think it has been taken
seriously by some flossers who work on
time consciousness I could be wrong with
that but I wanted to ask you back you
just gave you said it'd be nice if
philosophers could tell you what a
mechanistic explanation is now there's a
group I like the Peter makam er Karl
Craver if they had any influence these
people are the people who claim that
they've got it down and they interact
all the time with cognitive scientists
and cognitive neuroscientists and all
they write about is or bill Bechtel so
you never heard you heard his name so
that's just interesting right because
there is a group of people who claim to
do this very thing and you didn't hear
about them just as you hadn't heard
about Samira shotgun no review so this
is kind of a just a feature of the
intellectual division of labor that's
right sort of in front of us right now
awesome your your comment about well
it's kind of some turkey triumphalist
philosophy fest but one of the things
that really either destruct me when you
sent the list of questions was these are
awful these are hardcore philosophical
freewill morality you know
holiday what else do you have there I
mean you know meaning I mean this is the
hardcore stuff philosophers do not have
something you know a lot to say about
this and these are all philosophers you
take science very very seriously and try
to absorb as much of you know as the
relevant science as is possible
but yet have more to say even one would
hope then the scientists you know well
there's just no excuse for a philosophy
departments then I mean it would have to
be it seems to me um you know that the
philosophers would have a lot to say
here this is hardcore stuff so what what
they spend their entire lives thinking
about
you